(man) The sharks are back
in an all-New season
of "Shark tank,"
where Hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners...
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
You are a nasty beast.
I'm not a nasty beast.
I like that.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
there's $50,000
on the table.
Can you convince
another shark to play?
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
The energy shots that are
out right now suck.
(imitates French accent)
a delicious looking morsel, no?
(both laugh)
(laughs)
When you first came out,
I thought you were
two bozos in a boat,
but you're not so dumb.
It's sink...
(laughs) Do you know
how crazy that sounds?
Or swim.
I like it a lot.
I'll give you
what you want.
What?
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand FUBU.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
My name is Jackie Courtney,
and I live
in Brooklyn, New York.
When I got married
a year ago,
I had a hard time finding
a dress that I loved
and that I could afford.
I, like most brides,
want that dream dress
that I've seen in magazines.
Those dresses, however,
cost upwards of $10,000,
which is a price,
in today's economy,
that most girls can't afford.
My business, nearly newlywed,
is an online boutique
for modern brides
to buy and sell high-End,
nearly new wedding dresses.
And let me know if you
have any other questions.
I'm totally available.
This business means a lot to me.
Right now, I'm working
out of my 1-Bedroom apartment
and there's wedding
dresses everywhere.
I need an investment
from the sharks
so I can take a great idea
and turn it into
the big business that
I know it can be.
It's just the beginning.
Hi. My name's Jackie,
and the name of my company
is nearly newlywed.
I'm here today asking
for a $35,000 investment
in exchange for 10% ownership
in my company.
Nearly newlywed
is an online boutique
that's offering
a new way for girls
to shop
for their wedding dresses.
When I was growing up
in iowa,
I couldn't get enough
of the glitz and glamour
I saw in magazines,
so I moved to New York city
to be a part of it all.
I went to work
as a fashion publicist,
getting to dress
celebrities and editors,
and what really surprised me
was that they all borrowed
everything
they wore on the red carpet.
Unfortunately,
I'm not a celebrity,
which I quickly realized
when planning my wedding.
The dresses I loved
were so expensive.
So I created
nearly newlywed.
Let me take you
on a quick tour.
If you visit our site,
you can see some of the newest
dresses we've gotten in,
like this marchesa.
This marchesa gown retails
for $11,000 in stores,
But at nearly newlywed,
you can have it
for just $3,800.
What's even better
is our sell-it-back guarantee.
After your wedding,
you can sell it back to us
for 50% of what you paid,
making this $11,000 dress
available to girls
for only $1,900.
The inspiration for what I'm
doing was really my own wedding.
I was married last June
to my husband Patrick.
That same dress
has been worn
by multiple brides,
as you can see in just
a sampling of their photos here.
And here it is,
looking gorgeous
on Kate today.
We just launched,
but our growth
has been incredible.
So I would love
to partner with one of you
to meet the demand.
Jackie, I thought that women
loved to keep their dress.
I think that the mentality,
what a woman wants on her
wedding day, has really changed.
I mean, arguably,
it is a very personal,
sentimental purchase.
Well, Jackie,
let's ask Barbara.
She's been married
eight times.
(laughs)
You know,
I've been married twice,
and I almost didn't keep
my first wedding dress,
but I wore it again
when I found my second husband.
You did?
Yes.
So there you go.
You're a perfect example
of wearing it again.
But let me ask you--
to me, what's the difference
between this and renting a gown?
There's nothing
that's long-term,
flexible, and has
the selection that we have.
This is essentially
the convenience of renting
with options.
You can alter it.
It's yours, in your closet.
Can you alter a rental gown?
Uh, no.
Oh, well,
that's an important difference.
It's like a used car.
She buys it, she sells it,
she buys it, she sells it.
I mean, they can't,
you know, Dye the dress purple.
How many do you have
in inventory now?
We started with just 30,
and we just tripled
our inventory
in the last--last week.
Tripled?
So you're laying out capital?
You buy these?
We're not laying out
any capital.
How--Oh, do tell.
We have almost
$300,000 worth of inventory
of--That's the resale price,
not the retail price.
When you buy
that $11,000 dress,
what are you paying
for it?
Nothing.
So you're getting them
on consignment from who?
We're getting them
on consignment from brides...
Ah.
Stylists, and we are--
Actually,
we've already
been approached
by designers and boutiques
to collaborate.
So you do not pay
for the inventory
until you have sold it?
That's correct.
(Barbara) That's a huge profit.
So you're ebay--You're ebay
for wedding dresses.
(Barbara) And no cash flow--
Interesting, Jackie.
Interesting.
You are a nasty beast,
Jackie.
So you actually hold--
I'm not a nasty beast.
I like that.
I'm trying to help girls.
I really am.
Like, it's really
what I wanna do.
I want to ask
this question. All right.
So run me through
the economics--
So a girl sells you
her dress at $2,000.
What do you sell
the dress at?
We like to price a gown,
unless it's very current,
and really in demand--
So you have
a standard margin?
Yes. It's 30% to 40%.
If a woman is looking
at an $11,000 dress
and she can't afford it,
why doesn't she buy
an $800 dress?
I don't think
that's our girl.
I think it's a girl
that can afford a $5,000
and buys a $10,000.
My daughters are now
planning their wedding dress,
and they're 14.
Mm-hmm. Right.
(laughs)
I hope it's a long way away.
Right.
But it's such--
Just hope there's
no shotguns involved.
Well, no, but, you know,
it's such a personal thing
for them.
No, it is,
but if they came to you
and said...
I'm thinking the only time
a woman is gonna get
a used dress
is if she's divorced.
I completely disagree.
(laughs)
If your daughter
came to you
and said,
"I want a $20,000 dress,"
and I said, "I have
that dress for her for $7,000."
Do you think that she
wouldn't give it a chance,
try it on?
No, I'd say,
"call uncle mark,
and he'll pay it for you."
Yeah.
All they--All that
matters is,
does it look good
when they're wearing it,
and does it look good
in the pictures, right?
What are your sales, Jackie?
Well, we just launched,
so, I mean, our sales data
is pretty small,
because--
But what are they?
What are they?
Walk us through a dress.
We've sold 4
of our first 30 dresses
in the last 30 days.
Four dresses?
That's nothing.
Right, but we just started.
Looking forward,
how are you gonna get
from now to success?
Number one
is building our inventory.
And I think another big Piece
is continuing
the press run we're on.
I mean, we've had--
We've just been featured
by "the Washington post,"
and "Ink" magazine
and "Mashable" Wrote about us
because they think
that we're doing
interesting things
in the tech space.
You built that traffic
because of this initial rush
in P.R.?
Mm-Hmm.
That's very difficult
to sustain.
How are you going to maintain
that type of traffic?
Girls are sharing this
themselves. It's not just p.R.
So facebook is actually
one of the ways
that is driving
the majority of our traffic.
And we have a lot of things
in the works.
We're going to be
in "Martha Stewart,"
recommended things
for the fall issue.
Are you paying for that?
No, we're not.
It's editorial.
And I'm also going to be
featured in "Marie Claire,"
in Their, um,
under-35 entrepreneurs.
We're, um, in talks
to partner with kleinfeld's,
which is one of
the first boutiques
we've been talking with,
um, because we identified them
as, obviously,
the gold standard.
And what would your deal
with them potentially be?
So we're talking
about a few different things.
Um, you know,
they've seen a surge
in women wanting
to sell their gowns.
So recommending
their brides come to us,
we're sort of their
preferred person
for them to consign dresses.
You know, you have a perfect
background for this business,
coming from the P.R. Field.
Yeah, it's definitely been
something that's really helped.
And you're articulate
and you hustle.
Thank you.
All great.
But you know what?
You've been in business
three months,
and you haven't proven
your model.
It's an idea.
It's not a business.
No. It's a baby business.
Certainly.
She's up and running.
Four dresses sold?
(daymond)
Call four dresses a business?
You're up and running.
You've birthed it, okay?
Yes.
Good for you.
Not easily done.
But it is
only three months,
and it's such a wild card.
You haven't proven
your model,
so I'd be afraid
I wouldn't get my money out.
You would get
your money out.
For that--
How would I get
my money out?
If you invested, I would hustle
until you got every penny back,
and more.
But it's three months,
it's not tested.
Too early for me.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Jackie, look, I've been
married for 23 years.
I've been married
to the same woman.
We bought the dress
that we could afford,
and it's really meaningful
to her, to me...
I'm gonna cry, Robert.
And for our kids,
so I-I just don't
buy into the concept.
Right. I-I mean,
I understand.
That's not
the entire market.
I just think
that's not...
that's not everybody.
No, I hear you,
but I don't believe
in this concept.
I'm out.
Jackie, isn't it True
that one of the reasons you want
to keep the wedding dress
is to see if your wife
fits in it 20 years later?
(sharks laugh)
And in your case, Kevin,
what's the answer?
Thank goodness.
(laughs)
I love this space,
and I recently got
educated in this space.
And what I recently
got educated on is,
this is the only time
that a female has no rationale,
when it comes to purchasing
on her wedding day.
And--and that's why
I find the space attractive,
because the margins
are 7,000%.
You're starting
to sound like Kevin, daymond.
I want to be
in this space
for the luxury
and the opulence
and the ability to sell
something that's $4
for $4,000.
This does not fit my model.
I'm out.
All right, Jackie. You know,
this is such a crapshoot.
But I like you and I like
how feisty you are.
I gotta have a big chunk
of this thing
if I'm gonna do it,
so I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you the 35k.
I want 40%.
40%?
Yep.
It's an absolute bet on you.
And, you know, you're either
gonna make it or you're not,
but because I love love...
You love love?
I'm willing
to take a chance.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Jackie has an offer
on the table from Kevin,
but he wants 30% more equity
than she initially offered.
I'll give you the 35k.
I want 40%.
40%?
Yep.
Are there
any other offers?
All roads lead
to Mr. Wonderful.
All roads?
You know what?
I'm a romantic.
Are you?
I love weddings.
I cry at all weddings.
You--You do?
Yes.
All right. All right.
I cry to see 50%
of somebody's net worth
going out the window.
(laughs)
(mark) I think it's
a very good idea.
I think you're on
your way to something,
but you're too press-Driven,
and it's too you-driven.
I think your taste
is just so specific
that that'll hurt
the business,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
He's telling you why
I need 40%.
The risk is so huge.
It's an absolute bet on you.
And, you know, you're either
gonna make it or you're not.
Can you come down
a little bit?
No chance, Jackie.
Because we are--
No chance?
Zero chance.
Zero chance?
Zero.
40%, final offer.
That's it.
I was gonna ask for 51%...
Oh, really?
So I could fire you
if it didn't work.
But I'm not that kind of guy.
(laughs)
Um, then respectfully,
I think I'm gonna
have to decline.
But I thank you
for your time.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Good for you.
I like you more now.
(Robert) Wow.
Good for you.
Kevin--Dumped
at the altar again.
Again.
Jackie, you're dead to me.
(sharks laugh)
Good luck, Jackie.
Thank you.
See you guys.
You know what? Discount weddings
are the future.
You'd rather put the $10,000
into the down payment
on a house.
Wouldn't you rather
buy a $600 dress
that you keep forever?
No!
You don't wear dresses.
Forget about that.
Don't women go back
and look at that stuff?
No, not on a wedding day.
You don't know women, Robert,
like I do.
(Kevin and Barbara laugh)
♪♪♪
in season two,
we watched Aldo Orta
make a deal
with Kevin Harrington
and Barbara Corcoran
for his eponymous
designer jewelry collection,
Aldo Orta.
(Barbara) I think
you look the part.
Let's see
what he's up to now.
So many wonderful things
happened to me
since "Shark tank."
Finally, we're going to show
This amazing collection on qvc.
We're live on the air.
Aldo is here.
Thank you for calling.
Now I have
an amazing contract for qvc
and my sales increased 70%.
Now you're designing
for the queen, queen Elizabeth?
I got a commission to create
this beautiful piece
for queen Elizabeth.
If you've seen him
on "Shark tank"
and you're going,
"I do wanna try his designs"--
he's done it for the queen.
Why not for you?
Closing the deal
with Barbara and Kevin
has been the best decision
I ever done in my life.
Thanks to "Shark tank,"
I live the American dream.
♪♪♪
(Robert chuckles)
Ahoy, everyone.
I'm captain Nathan buffet.
And I'm Shane cianciolo.
We're here seeking $105,000 for
20% equity in our business...
corks away.
(pops)
People come
from all over the world
to experience our amazing
wine adventure on the high seas.
Upon arrival,
you are greeted
by a coast guard-Approved
captain.
You then proceed
to board the "sunflower,"
our luxurious
30-Foot wine vessel.
Now once Everyone
is safe and secure,
your vessel is ready
for departure.
(clangs)
on board, your senses
will come alive...
(laughs)
As you experience the majesty
of the open waterways
and indulge
in our premium wine tasting.
Welcome aboard.
Thank you.
Your wine host
serves and explains
each of the four
wines and appetizers
that are presented to you
during your ride.
How nice is this?
Good timing.
Oh, welcome aboard.
Thank you.
Now this allows you
to relax... (sighs)
And enjoy your time
out on the water.
Nathan, is this
a singles Cruise?
Should I be hitting on Barbara?
(sharks laugh)
Thank you.
Mmm.
One of our specialty appetizers
is the renowned pesto torte.
(imitates French accent)
a delicious looking morsel, no?
(both laugh)
(Barbara) Ha!
We've served
thousands of guests,
and many return every year
for the intangible experience
that we call...
Wait for it.
(drumroll plays)
Wine on the water.
L-O-L-O-L.
(laughs)
We do offer a variety
of different types of cruises.
Uh, you can choose from
beers and cheers cruises,
mimosa cruises,
couples cruises,
sunset cruises--
Whatever the occasion,
we have an atmosphere
specifically tailored
and waiting for you.
So who wants
to come aboard,
and help take
corks away's wine on the water
to the world?
So basically, guys,
it's a booze Cruise
with bad theater?
Well...
(laughs)
It's not a booze Cruise,
it is an experience
for an hour and a half
with only six guests.
And is Nathan
a certified captain?
I am, sir.
Are you seasonal
or All year round?
12 Cruises per week,
all year round.
So why are you here today?
Do you want more boats?
We want to expand. We're
actually stage two of four.
Stage one
was proof of concept.
Uh, we currently have sales
of $250,000 from last year.
(mark and Kevin) Whoa.
(Barbara) Wow!
When you first came out,
I thought you were
two bozos in a boat,
but you're not so dumb.
You've got almost a quarter of
a million in sales on one boat.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
That's not bad.
So go on with your stages.
Uh, stage two is expansion,
and we've found that we--we can
expand this business
into a franchise
for captains who need
a way to make money.
Are you gonna go
to charter captains and say,
"look, you give us your boat,
"you be the captain.
"I have another way
for you to make revenue
when your boat
is not making money."
You're absolutely on it.
To expand their business?
This is an opportunity
for any captain who's wanted
to be able
to own their own business.
He either got a boat,
or he's got his captain license
and wants a boat
and doesn't have one yet.
For $175,000,
we will give you a boat.
We also give you the business
plan to work the boat,
meaning that we have
all of the tools necessary.
So that's
your franchise model?
That's our franchise model.
That's correct.
Interesting.
We make money through--
You sell the guy the boat
for $175,000.
What do you pay for it?
The boat only costs us $35,000.
And you're gonna sell it
to the Skipper for $175,000?
With our business plan, yes.
(high-Pitched voice) What?!
whoa!
(Robert) Come on!
There's no way you're--
Do you really think
you can do that?
Do you really think the guy
who's buying the boat
wouldn't know that the original
boat Only costs $35,000?
What we're selling is the--
and while we're contemplating
those margins,
get me some more wine.
(laughs) Yeah, no kidding!
Yes, sir!
I can do that right now!
(mark) I'm down for that.
A big part of owning
your own business
is customer service
and problem solving.
You understand that
you need to, uh--
I'm gonna understand it better
with one more glass, though.
(laughter)
Well, let's--Let's get you
drinking, mark.
That's what we can do here.
Stage three?
Stage Three is actually
to go to our pesto torte,
which you're trying there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
And stage four--
Pesto torte phase?
(mark laughs)
What is that?
The pesto torte is what
we think--a great appetizer,
and we would love to be able
to market that to stores.
(Kevin and daymond laugh)
You're gonna be selling
this little dish I just enjoyed
to stores as a piece
of your business plan?
They're not.
They're absolutely not,
but what I figured was you guys
might want a piece of that.
Our focus, you know, is--
(laughs) It's like a bonus
you throw in.
I just wanna really make sure
that I heard what you said.
You put three crackers here
and whatever This is on this,
and you're gonna also create
an ancillatory business
selling this to stores?
(laughs) the pesto.
If you guys see that
as a feasibility, then yes.
If not,
then that's not our focus.
And stage four,
if you wanna know,
is to make an indoor dinner ride
in las vegas.
(men) WHOA!
(Barbara) Wow!
Yeah!
Indoor--We left the ocean
and everything?
(laughing)
We wanna take it indoors.
We want it--
a boat experience indoors?
Now that's--That's years
and years down the line.
I did not see stage four coming,
I gotta be honest.
Inside for adult alcoholics?
For adult alcoholics, correct.
Cheer, cheer!
Captain, my captain.
Hip, hip, hoorah!
Well, usually after
you start drinking
the boat starts rocking anyway,
right?
(laughs)
You're making money,
you're--You're having fun
with it.
You know, all you do is drive
around drunk people--Cheers--
And have a great time.
Here's the problem I have--
you can't scale.
You're limited in the number
of boats you can place
in any one bay.
I understand.
And you're really limited
in how many places you can go.
I'm looking for
a significant return.
I just can't get there.
I'm taking the anchor.
I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
(Robert) Here's the best thing
about your business.
When you can be in business with
somebody you get along with,
that's magical.
Thank you.
But beyond phase one,
there's a lot of holes
in this boat.
It's just not adding up.
I'm out.
Robert, I hear ya.
Our whole goal is to get
to this indoor ride...
(laughter)
And there are steps
to get there.
Shane, do you know
how crazy that sounds?
It was really crazy for people
to open up a casino
in--in a desert.
True.
Hey, listen,
I think there's
another marketing angle.
So let's say you do something
like the riesling ride.
Right?
Oh, that's a great idea.
That's right, right? So what
is that? Two r's, right?
Yep.
If you add
the relaxing riesling ride,
what would that be?
Oh, lord.
Arr.
"arr, arr, arr."
(laughter)
Right? Yeah.
That's what
I'm falling in love with.
But I have to be honest, guys.
I'm out.
Daymond, thank you for
your time. I appreciate it.
Arr!
I was wrong. I called it
bad theater. It's good theater.
It's good theater.
You guys are comics,
and I actually think you got
a nice little business here.
I would love to have you all
aboard. That would be--
That would really solidify
what it is that we do.
I love boats.
I enjoyed our time together.
I like the wine, also.
Thank you, Kevin.
If there's any left,
I'll have some more.
How many glasses have you had?
I'll keep going...
(mark) Keep going, Kevin...
'cause this deal is just getting
better by the glass.
'cause you finally get
a personality when you drink.
So the way I look at it is,
at the end of the day,
it's not investable,
but it's not horrible.
Just not investable.
There's no way
to get a return from this.
In five years,
we believe--
Now if I have one more glass,
I may change my mind.
(daymond) Ooh.
But you know what?
You're have a great time.
You're making money. You made it
to the shark tank.
You're very nice guys.
Having said all that,
I'm so out.
(chuckles) Thank you, Kevin.
I appreciate it.
Cheers.
Well, Barbara,
it's really up to you,
and we really hope
that you'll consider us.
Come on,
you're such wacky characters.
I would have so much fun
sailing with you guys,
but I couldn't sleep at night
if you had my money.
You're a lot of fun, guys,
but unfortunately I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara,
and I appreciate all your time.
Thanks, guys.
(Shane) Thank you.
(Nathan) Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
I'm the first to buy a ticket
on the indoor ride.
(laughs)
Wow, that was fun.
(daymond) Poor guys.
I have to tell you something,
though, Kevin.
You get a lot nicer once
you have a little bit of wine.
Just keep it coming.
♪♪♪
Next up are David powers
and Scott tindel
with an innovative resource
for the sharply dressed man.
My name is David powers...
and I'm Scott tindel.
And we're the founders
of tietry.
We're asking you
for a $100,000 investment
in exchange for
a 25% equity stake in tietry.
Tietry is essentially
netflix for neckties.
Scott and I,
both being attorneys,
wear a lot of ties.
But we realized that we were
wearing the same few
over and over.
When we started talking
to other people,
we found out other guys were
just like us.
And that's why a few months ago,
we launched tietry.
Our subscribers get an unlimited
number of neckties delivered
directly to their doorstep
for a low monthly price.
They choose the ties they want
and exchange them
as often as they want.
For the price of
a couple of cups of coffee,
our subscribers
can literally wear
hundreds of dollars worth
of designer neckties
every single month.
We know that tietry is
the perfect business
to break into
the men's access market.
So... y'all wanna tie one on
with tietry?
Okay, guys, what does it cost
you to acquire a customer?
'cause I've never heard
of tietry before.
We launched a few months ago.
So far, we've spent virtually
nothing on advertising.
All--We've been getting our
customers through free press,
free publicity,
and through referrals.
(Robert)
That's the entire model?
Yes.
How many users
do you have today?
Oh, we have approximately
110 subscribers right now.
And the reason is, we took
these first six months
and we're using it as
a proof of concept.
Before we dumped a significant
amount of money into this,
we wanted to be able
to prove
that this would do
what we thought it did.
I wear a tie every day.
I spend thousands every year
on ties.
I buy them
all around the world.
You do? Really?
I look--And I look spectacular.
But they're all black.
(men laugh)
I look spectacular in them.
Now at the end of the day,
what I wanna know is,
where you add value for me?
Well, k-Kevin,
here's how we add value.
For example, our most--Our most
popular plan right now,
the two tie at a time plan,
that's $15.99 a month.
If you're diligent about
when you receive your ties,
wearing it, and sending it back
the next day,
you can get up to 8 to 10 ties
per month.
A lot of our ties retail
anywhere from $80 to $90.
So that's over $700 a month
for $15 a month.
How do we send it back?
Um...
well, I'll actually--I'll
show you the, uh, packages
that you would receive.
Gentlemen, most of
the sharks here, I'm sure,
spend $300
on every tie they wear.
(mark) not me.
(Robert) or more.
Not you? Good for you
not me.
For mark,
we have the cuban plan.
That's where you only need a tie
once a year
so that you can go to
the White House.
(Robert laughs)
How do you get
more subscribers?
We're gonna implement
a referral program.
We've found that
our best advertisers
are guys that wear our ties,
and they go out, and people say,
"Hey, that's a great tie.
Where'd you get it?"
and they say, "It's tietry.
It's a rental."
Well, are you planning on
Carrying any other category?
Any other haberdashery such as
cuff links? Anything else?
We--we are. Yes.
We can go to cuff links,
suspenders,
vests, watches, sunglasses.
Well, and the beauty of it is,
for $16 a month,
if you get the tie and you don't
like it, you just send it back.
There's no commitment either,
so somebody can sign up
for, you know, $16,
and--And if they say, "this
isn't for me," they just cancel.
Or if you need a tie
for a special event--
You realize there's
a challenge here, guys.
'cause how long have you
actually been renting the ties?
We launched in January--
Uh, basically a soft launch.
So you really haven't had to
deal with the issue of turn.
Yet you know people can cancel
at any moment.
What percentage of turn
do you think you'll get?
Well, our--Our--Our renewal rate
is, uh, basically 85% so far.
So 15% turn so far?
But there's Only
110 subscribers.
Yeah, that's not the problem.
Look,
the--the problem is, guys,
how--How long do you think you
can sustain getting free press?
Well, let's give you
the benefit of the doubt.
A thousand people
subscribed.
You guys danced around
your apartments
and you high fived,
and "ooh! A thousand people!"
but it's Only gonna take
a 15% turn per month,
it's gonna take
less than seven months
for those thousand
to disappear,
and you have to
replace them.
If we do lose
those 15% of subscribers,
the next 15% of subscribers
we get,
we don't have to replace
inventory for them
'cause we already have
the inventory for them.
But that's great,
but it's not my point.
N-No, let--Let me address
your point.
With our subscription model,
if we sell
a thousand subscriptions,
the next month, we're gonna sell
a thousand subscriptions.
(Robert) I love that model.
It's a fantastic model.
I just don't think you have
enough of a subscriber base
to justify the business.
I think you just gotta
test it out a little more.
I'm out.
Well, and--Both Scott and I,
we've been working
during the day and night,
living on 5-Hour energy drink,
basically.
Uh, but w-When Scott leaves
his job,
he'll--He'll be able to sell.
Okay, no, stop right there.
Who is he going to sell to?
Are you just gonna walk
up and down the street
and say, "buy a subscription
to tietry"?
Well, if I could go downtown
in downtown mobile
and go to
the biggest office building
where there are hundreds of guys
wearing ties
and go sign up ten guys a day...
go on to the next city.
But then what?
Well--
then you'll be hanging yourself
with those ties.
Daymond, we've been approached
by Three different
college students
on different campuses, wanting
to be campus reps from us.
And--
All right,
let's stop right there.
I'm gonna make things
a little interesting
here in the shark tank.
I like you guys, all right?
But I don't wanna be perceived
as a greedy Mr. Wonderful.
So I'm gonna say I'll put up
$50,000 of what you need,
and I won't say for how much.
I'll let some other shark--
If you can convince one,
or sharkette--Decide
how much of the company
we should own
for the $100,000.
It won't be me.
Boy, I like me sometimes.
(laughs)
You're quite the gentlemen.
There's $50,000 on the table.
Can you convince another shark
to play?
♪♪♪
One shark is out.
Kevin has offered
half the money they are seeking
if they can get another shark
on board.
There's $50,000 on the table.
Can you convince another shark
to play?
And let them set
how much of the company should
be taken for that $100,000.
Okay.
Well, with that in mind,
I would love to ask Robert
if he'd be interested
in coming back in,
since now he knows that
he wouldn't be on the hook
for that full $100,000.
If--I know you were interested.
Oh, I-I don't think the $100,000
was--Was my issue.
I'm out at this point.
You've got three sharks left.
Two don't wear a tie.
Barbara?
But I have a strong opinion
on it,
even though
I don't wear a tie.
I think your young guy market
is the perfect person.
I, in fact, very much like
the idea you just mentioned
about marketing it through
college kids.
There's nothing more fun
than getting a little package
in the mail.
Popping out a fresh new tie.
And plus,
they're easy to ship.
But what I don't like is that
you only have 110 subscribers.
You can't get an investor
in this deal yet.
It hasn't been proven.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Barbara.
Ooh.
So close, yet so far.
(laughs)
Daymond, as you know, it's about
who can get out there first
and who can gain
market share.
So I didn't hear
not one word about fashion
in this whole discussion.
Is that a good or bad thing?
I didn't hear about
double Windsor knots.
(Robert) wow.
I didn't hear about how a check
would lay with this,
or the cuff links
and the beauty and the love,
and the excitement about
the beauty of a tie.
Mm.
And for that reason, you're not
obsessed over this business
like we all are
over our businesses.
I'm out.
Amen! Well said.
Wow.
(Kevin) ooh.
Boy, that's cold.
Well, as our sign
back here says,
we believe a stately neck
is manhood's manliest part.
And So, uh, we do feel
that way.
I'm sorry we didn't get there
sooner, obviously.
There's one
non-Tie-Wearing shark left.
Well, mark, we're asking you
to invest in us.
We--we can make this work.
One question--What's your cost
of customer acquisition
once you get beyond
the P.R. Phase?
Because
it's proof of concept,
we're still trying to find
that number.
But we believe that we can
provide customers
at about $10 to $12 a month,
which is about the cost
of one month's subscription.
But you've never tested that.
We--we had some testing,
but we certainly don't have
mountains and mountains of data
at this point.
The--but with
the referral program,
uh, you know, that--
That would cost us about--
That would be about $10 a month.
That's a stretch.
You guys are guessing.
You guys are hoping.
You don't have a solution.
You haven't
thought this through.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Ouch!
Ouch. I was the only one
that believed in you.
It's not too late,
Mr. Wonderful.
And you failed to convince
one other shark,
and now all I can say is
you're both dead to me.
I'm out.
Bye.
(mark and daymond)
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
(Barbara) Good luck.
♪♪♪
(Robert) Daymond, that was
such a great point. Never--
and he would know that.
He's a fashion guy.
And I couldn't put my finger
on what was wrong with it.
They had no passion.
They l--No passion.
Daymond, you were--
Were dead on it.
You nailed it.
All right.
Even though we didn't get a deal
with the sharks,
we feel like, uh, they really
believed in what we were doing.
We were just here
a little too early.
♪♪♪
My name is rob Dyer.
I'm a major in
the United States Marine corps,
and I'm stationed
in annapolis, Maryland.
(calling cadence)
currently,
I'm a military professor
at the United States
naval academy.
When I'm not teaching
at the academy,
I'm a husband, I'm a father,
and I'm a business owner.
Boom!
My family's awesome.
I have a beautiful wife.
I have a 3-year-Old son.
Mwah!
♪♪♪
(clicks)
the inspiration for the product
came while I was deployed,
serving my country
with marines Spec ops forces
in Afghanistan.
Typical mission for us
might last five to seven days.
The only food we had
was the food we were actually
carrying with us.
(men cheering)
Our product helps you perform
at your Peak every single day.
Up!
(men) one!
We developed this product
for marines spec ops forces.
Like ourselves.
If it's great
for marines spec ops,
it'll probably be great
for everybody at home
fighting their own battles.
If we don't get an investment
from the sharks,
we'll continue to try and grow
as fast as we can.
But with our small amount
of capital,
we cannot keep up with demand.
I can't help but think
that there's people out there
fighting
that don't have our product
that should.
♪♪♪
(lowered voice)
Do not mess with him.
Mnh-Mnh.
Good evening, sharks.
My name is Rob Dyer.
I'm an active duty
Marine corps officer
and my product is
ruckpack combat nutrition.
I'm seeking $75,000
for 10% of my company.
What is ruckpack?
It's the world's first
Peak performance nutrition shot,
and it was designed and tested
by Spec ops forces.
Typical missions for us
last up to a week or more,
and the only food we have
is the food we carry with us.
Because of this,
virtually all of us are taking
some sort of supplement
or energy shot,
and the energy shots
that are out right now suck.
They suck.
They boost you up
and then they bring you
right down with a crash.
And in that environment,
lives can be lost if you're not
operating at 100%.
So a team of marines
created ruckpack.
We all want energy,
but our snipers insist on it
being caffeine-free energy.
Sitting behind
the sniper scope for hours
is exhausting,
But caffeine jitters
simply aren't an option for us.
Ruckpack helps you increase
your mental acuity
so that we can shoot, move,
and communicate
faster than the enemy.
So I brought some
for you guys to try.
Thanks, rob.
Sir.
Thank you, sir.
Yes, ma'am.
Sir.
I can't even open it. (chuckles)
(laughs)
You'll need a couple of 'em
before you get the strength,
sir.
(sharks laugh)
Thank you.
Like I said, we built this
for the war fighter,
But everyone has
a battle to win.
With your capital
and our business plan,
ruckpack will help everyone win
life's battles.
Thank you
for this incredible opportunity.
I'll answer any questions
you have.
Let me first say thank you
for serving our country.
Absolutely.
Yes, sir. Absolutely.
We're not here without you.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
This story is so fantastic
for all the servicemen.
They know exactly what
you're talking about.
Are you trying
to translate that story
into the general population,
saying,
this is better
than anything else
because it's good enough
for you?
Is that the story?
Yes, sir,
that's exactly what happened.
We built it by
the symptoms that we wanted
to fix out in the field.
When everybody else
started calling us
and saying, "Hey, I hear you got
this spec ops shot.
How do I get my hands on it?"
who is the "Everybody else"
That started calling you,
and how did they find out
about it?
Friends and family. We spent
zero money on marketing.
Can I buy this in Retail?
Uh, you can buy it
in some small retail stores.
Like some independent--Like,
quantico, Virginia...
(chuckles) for a while
was locked down
with all the independent
7-Eleven owners,
the marines shops there--
You know, the uniform stores--
All had ruckpack
on the counter.
Are they still selling it?
No, they're out, sir.
So you don't have
any inventory right now...
correct.
And you need capital
for inventory?
We immediately took everything
we had an reinvested it,
and I've got 80,000 shots
on their way
in the next 10 to 15 days.
(daymond)
What does "Ruck pack" mean?
Is there a significance
behind the name?
Yes. So a military ruck
is that big backpack you wear,
with all the bags
and it carries all the gear.
Okay.
The great part about that ruck
is that you don't store
your favorite Pillow
from mommy,
or your favorite picture
of your doggie in there.
You only have in there
exactly what you need
and nothing else.
Got it. Okay.
Rob, I see here it says,
"prepared for
special operations forces."
Are you okay to say that?
You have their approval?
I'm okay to say exactly that.
It's not officially endorsed
by the Marine corps.
This is something
that was created
by Special operations forces
personnel.
(Robert) How did you know
what to put in it?
And do you have a patent on
a formula or some proprietary--
Well, we do have
proprietary ingredients
in the formula, ma'am.
But we have...
some ingredients
have to be disclosed
because of, you know,
recommended daily allowances
and we do that,
but we do have some ingredients
that are proprietary
just for us.
The ingredients themselves
are really not that--
I mean, they're--
they're important,
but that's not
the Barrier to entry.
The Barrier to entry
is marketing.
It's an energy drink,
and the differentiator is
army special ops.
So the challenge here is,
how do we get it out
into the general market?
With just a couple of tweaks,
it's a nutrition shot.
This is like a--This is like
a daily vitamin that you take.
You should have ruckpack.
If you take
a different energy shot,
you should really watch
when you use them
because they're really
not good for you.
So it's better?
This is good for you.
Okay.
This is healthy.
Are you working full-time now
in the military?
Yes, sir. I'm an active duty
Marine corps Officer.
My current duty station
is annapolis, Maryland.
Mm.
I'm an accounting professor
at the United States
naval academy.
And before you were that,
what were you in civilian life?
Well, before I was doing that,
I had jobs with Spec ops units.
Spec op units--
Are you in special forces?
Well, right now,
I'm an accounting professor.
But before that, were you?
(laughter)
Yes, sir.
You were in special forces?
So, rob,
since you--You're an accounting
professor right now
and you're working,
obviously...
Yes, sir.
"a," how much more time
do you have left
as an accounting professor
or your, um, your next--
Two and a half years.
So who runs the company while
you're operating as a professor?
Well, while I'm operating
as a professor,
that job ends for me
at 4:00 p.m. Every day.
I go home, spend a little time
with family,
and then I start ruckpack.
So you asked for $75,000
for 10%.
Yes, sir.
Um, so you're valuing
the company at $750,000.
Yes.
What--what do you want to do
with the money,
and where are you currently?
I want to scale
my manufacturing.
I know that if
I order enough,
I can work the cost down
to close to 50 cents.
And what's your cost today?
My costs today are about
80 to 85 cents.
80, 85.
(Robert) And what are you
selling it for today?
$2.19 online, and my direct
Sellers are getting $1.65.
When you sent out that product
before, it sold out.
Yes.
How many bottles?
How quick did it sell out?
15,000 shots in a little over
a month and a half.
Rob, do you have
any inventory today?
I have no inventory today.
The 80,000 shots
that we have coming in
will be here
in about 10 to 14 days.
Do you have to pay
for the inventory ahead of time?
I do.
So the minute
you place the order,
you gotta put the cash
out there?
I've put 50% of the cash up.
How much cash have you put in
so far?
Of my own personal money?
About $90,000 to $95,000.
Wow.
Whoa.
(Robert) of your money?
Yes.
And you mentioned "We"
a few times.
Do you have partners
in the business?
I do. We are--
The company itself has
16 total owners.
Wow.
It's 80% military family-Owned.
And what percentage do you own?
How much do you still own?
I own 43%.
My wife Owns almost 2%.
So, rob, you put up $90,000
or was the total
among 16 people?
I put $90,000.
And how much did you raise
from the other 15 people total?
Total amount in the company
is probably about $240,000-Ish.
Ooh.
And of--of that,
you put up $90,000 yourself?
Yes.
Wow.
What did you spend it all on?
Yeah, that seems like a lot.
Web sites, r&d.
We did
the first 20,000 shots,
so now
I still have the money
to already pay for
the 80,000 shots.
I also--Because caffeine is
the largest drug in the world--
I would be stupid
not to at least offer
a caffeinated shot,
so I have
20,000 of those coming
that I've already
paid for as well.
Okay, so you prepaid your--
No, product.
Basically,
you prepaid inventory.
Yes, sir. Yes, we have.
(daymond)
Yes, you have inventory.
Okay.
So is your biggest problem today
in your business
getting sales
or filling existing sales?
Filling existing.
I've got Sellers waiting--
That keep calling me.
"When will I get more?
When will I get more?"
so the $75,000 today,
I'm assuming,
is all going to buy inventory?
Yes.
Okay.
You're successful.
You're giving up 10% today
for $75,000.
What happens tomorrow?
It sounds like the business
isn't generating enough cash
for you to buy inventory.
What if you need another $75,000
or $200,000 or $500,000?
There's gotta be a different way
to build this business
than every time you grow,
having to sell equity
to pay for the inventory.
I think that with the 20,000
caffeinated shots I have coming
and the 80,000 shots that I have
of the nutrition shot,
I'll be able
to do that already.
The $75,000 that you give me
will just be so that there's
not a backlog.
Unfortunately, I've invested
in similar products that would
compete against this.
I'm out.
Understood. Thank you.
I appreciate your time.
Robert, I think you have
a compelling story.
And who wouldn't
fall in love with you?
I'm in love with you.
I'm a little in love
with you, too.
(laughs)
You're a Younger model of my
husband who went to annapolis,
and I think I'm gonna trade
him in and marry you instead.
(mark and Robert laugh)
But I am troubled
by the, uh, $240,000 invested.
It seems like a lot of money
for where you stand right now.
I'm also troubled by the fact
that you have...
43% interest?
Yes.
And you're willing to give away
another 10%, which puts you--
I just feel like you're
eating away at the company
and don't have enough
to show for it.
But everybody gets diluted,
not him.
(Robert) Yeah.
Yeah, okay, but I'm out.
The story's very powerful.
It's good enough for a sniper
on the battlefield,
and I want the same product
for me.
This whole jittery finger thing,
caffeine--I buy into 100%.
I get it. Everybody'll get that
right away.
Normally, I would want more,
but I like it a lot.
This is very uncharacteristic
of me.
I'll give you what you want.
What?!
I'll give you 75k for 10%.
I'll simplify things.
I love the idea.
I-I'd love the opportunity
to invest in you.
The problem is,
I only get half of you.
Business doesn't work
after 4:00 p.m. Time,
and it doesn't work
on a schedule.
And when things have to happen,
they have to happen.
You've gotta be there
when the business needs you,
and I don't see that
as being possible right now,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Okay. Understood.
Well, rob, here's what I know.
Marines always find a way.
They do.
So I'm not bothered by the fact
you--You have a full-Time job
serving the country until 4:00.
But I think you're gonna need
more cash
than the $75,000.
So... Here's what I'm thinking.
If Kevin will have me--
$150,000 from the two of us
for 20%.
You know what? Robert's right.
You need more cash.
I'll do that deal with him.
Now you've just doubled
what you came in here for.
I appreciate it.
I'll take $150,000 for 20%
from Mr. O'Leary
and Mr. Herjavec.
(Robert and Kevin) All right!
(mark) Congratulations, guys.
First thing we do is
we Mount operations,
take out both of his drinks.
(Barbara laughs)
Thanks, guys.
Really appreciate it.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Congrats, rob.
Thanks, guys.
(Robert) Yeah, thanks.
Team ruckpack is hugely excited
about this deal.
With twice as much money,
we can kick twice as much ass.